researchers have discovered jellyfish
sleep and have the same trouble that we
do waking up since jellyfish are very
low on the animal family tree the work
suggests that the ability to sleep
evolved quite early so how can you tell
an animal is napping and not just say
resting or in a coma for one we are
unresponsive to gentle nudging or sounds
but wake up immediately if we fall out
of bed or hear a loud enough noise if we
cut our sleep short we are groggy the
next day and sleep more soundly when we
finally do get back to bed
researchers decided to see if a
jellyfish whose nervous system isn't
centralized and doesn't include a brain
could also sleep they looked at several
species of upside-down jellyfish in the
genus Cassiopeia which tends to hang out
motionless with its modified tentacles
facing upward instead of downward like
corals but unlike most jellyfish
Cassiopeia hosts algae in their bodies
that help supply nutrients they pulse
their bowels once per second keeping
water flowing over their bodies to sweep
in food and clear away waste
the researchers monitor the pulsing of
23 animals day and night for almost a
week during the day the jellies pulsed
about 60 times per minute at night
the jellyfish slowed to about 39 pulses
to see if they were really asleep the
researchers lifted the animals off their
preferred place on the bottom of the
tanks and measured how quickly the
jellyfish started swimming back to the
bottom like a groggy person slow to get
moving in the morning the jellyfish were
slow to respond to being moved but they
did wake up if they were lifted again 30
seconds later they swim immediately down
to the bottom finally when some
jellyfish were deprived of sleep they
were not as active the next morning but
they did recover the next day
that sleeping evolved in these animals
suggests that it's not just brains that
need sleep but that individual nerve
cells may crave it as well it might also
mean that sleep was present in the very
first animals to exist on this planet
[Music]
you